I want to help you AMD free of charge
just drop by the lab and I'm gonna have
the team show you how to Benchmark a GPU
so then you can choose a price that
reflects its performance because
frankly you guys are all over the road
here the RX 7600 the card you're
launching today manages to get handily
out class by your own products is what I
was going to say then on Monday
afternoon just 39 hours from launch AMD
dropped the price let's go Gamers we're
gonna have a rough cut of our original
review on floatplane.com LTT if you're
curious by the way but the gist of it is
this we liked the card but didn't like
the price well now it is sixty dollars
less than the launch price of its
predecessor and it's within ten dollars
of our suggestion that we thought would
make it competitive which is nice
but then they also dropped the price on
some of their last gen products making
those even more attractiveer there is a
lot to unpack here but one thing we know
for sure is that thanks to AMD there are
finally some not one
some decent mainstream cards that Gamers
can actually afford
let's start with the new kid on the
Block the all-new Navi 33 GPU at the
heart of the 7600 is built on amd's
latest rdna3 architecture which comes
with some key benefits like the addition
of AI course that well don't seem to do
much right now but uh in the future
we're expecting that to change you know
fine wine driver development and all of
that and right out of the gate our dna3
also comes with substantially improved
Ray tracing performance
but then so does the competition and AMD
has only made things more difficult for
themselves just last month they were
over there throwing rocks at Nvidia over
the lack of memory on their more
Affordable Cards I guess they forgot
about their own glass house here but
this card is for 1080p where 8 gigs is
enough says AMD
unfortunately that's not entirely true
have a look
in f-122 AMD pulls off both a big win
and an own goal their last gen 6700 XT
leads the entire field beating even the
40 70 that costs almost twice as much
but then their shiny new 7600 Falls
squarely in the middle of the pack and
behind their own 6650xt a last gen card
that at press time costs anywhere from
10 to 30 dollars less
rough start and definitive proof that
you should completely ignore performance
rumors for upcoming products
in Far Cry 6 AMD manages to avoid
beating themselves at their own game by
keeping ahead of their own lower priced
cards albeit barely and the same goes
for Hitman 3 where the most interesting
result is actually the arc a770 Intel's
software team has clearly been working
their butts off to the point where they
now kind of sort of have a card that
manages to keep up with the competition
or it did anyway but can you keep up
with this message from our sponsor the
ridge Father's Day is coming up luckily
Ridge is having one of their biggest
sales of the Year give the dads in your
life a unique and functional Ridge
wallet or key case so they can do dad
things like brag about their wallet and
keys check the ridge out of the link
below and make Dad proud as we tested
more and more games we realized that the
main takeaway is that for 1080p gaming
you really don't need to spend more than
a few hundred bucks on a replacement for
your aging mid-tier GPU even in returnal
and cyberpunk we saw average frame rates
above 60 FPS across our entire stable of
modern cards even if the one percent
lows are a bit lower with that said
there is a big asterisk here look at the
results for the Last of Us Part One the
3060 has been quietly getting its butt
handed to it the whole time and then
boom it's out in front of the 7600
interesting we're going to talk about
that in a moment first if you're a 1080p
gamer amd's new card seems to slot into
their lineup very nicely falling behind
its bigger older brother the 6700 XT by
about 20 in both price and performance
while it's little though still older
brother the 6650 XT gives up just five
percent performance on average and
doesn't net you much in the way of
savings given that this is a newer GPU
that will likely receive driver support
for longer the 7600 is getting very
close to a recommendation here kind of
like how we'd recommend an insulated
water bottle from ltdstore.com but first
we need to talk about vram both Team
Green and team red are adamant that 8
gigs of gddr6 is enough for 1080p
and yet we found real world examples of
games that did struggle especially those
pesky PlayStation ports this was very
apparent when we saw the 30 60 12 gig
suddenly outperforming the supposedly
faster RX 7600 and whether you like it
or not this is going to be a trend
Gamers for over a decade now consoles
have been what dictates the rate of
growth for Hardware requirements it's no
coincidence that the PS5 and the Xbox
series X both feature a shared memory
architecture of 16 gigs and 10 gigs
respectively and now all of a sudden
we're seeing games developed for these
consoles that can demand significantly
more vram than an 8 gig GPU can provide
and with the potential for a
mid-generation refresh to these consoles
it's not entirely unrealistic to expect
that vram requirements could increase
further in the coming years take it with
a grain of salt rumors and all of that
the issue on top of that though is all
of this is just for 1080p if you own a
1440p display you you might desire that
extra vram today right now across our
suite of games in 1440p our rankings
remain largely similar to the 1080p
results but it should be noted that the
cards with the extra vram tend to hold
their positions better Intel in
particular starts to pull ahead and even
manage some small victories where it
lost before and the 30 60 12 gig holds
its position despite its much weaker GPU
of course we were a lot more upset about
all of this before the 7600 got a new
price point and Nvidia is clearly still
the worst offender
moving on we know these are obviously
not 4K cards at least not without the
help of their respective super sampling
Solutions but our pattern continues with
the 30 60 12 gig closing its performance
Gap versus the 7600 while Intel extends
its own to be clear we wouldn't
recommend any of these cards for 4K
Ultra gaming safe for the 4070 but
what's cool is that we no longer have to
say the same thing about Ray tracing
7600 isn't exactly a ray tracing monster
but it did better than we expected at
1080p native and looking at our results
with Fidelity effects super resolution
which has massively improved even if it
does still lag behind nvidia's dlss you
can get a decent 1440p gaming experience
although that is still a little like
saying my Civic can do 130 miles an hour
as long as it's on a steep hill so then
performance pretty solid for the price
and going with next-gen comes with other
upsides too right like a big leap
inefficiency no actually 20 more
performance over last gen is going to
cost you a 20 increase in total board
power I mean at least it doesn't
overheat though
yes it doesn't and while it isn't the
quietest card it's not offensively loud
despite its small size we also do get
DisplayPort 2.1 so that's cool but AMD
removed the one cable USBC output that
is so awesome on the 7900 series
so oh but what about productivity
well Nvidia dominates blender thanks to
its excellent Cuda integration and while
the av1 encoding times are competitive
with the more expensive 4060 TI that's a
nice Plus for YouTube streamers the RX
7600s h.264 and h.265 encoding are
nothing to write home about sorry twitch
streamers and in specview perf it sits
right in the middle of the pack though I
doubt that dazzling productivity
performance would have persuaded the
7600s target audience anyway
not that it really needs it assuming you
can actually find one at MSRP
7600 is and I can't believe I get to say
this for the first time in years an
attractive mainstream gaming card
however I'm sure we weren't the only
ones who were surprised by the price
change and amd's partners may have been
caught with board designs that make this
new price point impractical so it could
be some time before the market is flush
with sub 300 gpus at least from this gen
the good news is AMD has lots of other
options with fresh price Cuts as well
for as low as 320 bucks for the 6700 XT
you'll get a roughly 20 to 25
performance uplift for an equal bump in
price albeit with a higher cost of
ownership from its increased power draw
the 6650xt meanwhile is looking like a
pretty okay similarly priced alternative
and the 6600 it's kind of The Quiet star
of the show if you can get it for the
price we're seeing now just 200 dollar
reduce and then there's Nvidia who has
transitioned from making gpus for gamers
to making gpus for fans of Nvidia and
now it's time to see our original outro
for this video where I low-key
absolutely nailed it it's not a budget
productivity Workhorse nor is it a
mainstream level gaming godsend just
kind of sits there with its main
differentiators being shiny and new
is that the play then try and get people
who want the new shiny and aren't doing
much research
incoming transmission from the future
six months and in the wake of recent
catastrophic events AMD has decided to
slash prices on their 7600. now that
it's available for 259.99 it's gone from
no buy to no brainer and it's an
especially good value compared to the
4060 which is still 300 because Nvidia
Don't Do No Price drops
anyway amd's AI course uh they they do
something now so that's cool and if any
of this is wrong just be sure to tune in
to the WAN show on Friday November 24th
2023 to let future Linus know that he
went to the wrong time oh oh God they're
coming oh
don't forget to tell us
about
the Segway
to our sponsor
Messi it's springtime which means rain
can still show up and ruin your day like
an annoying neighbor but that's fine
because hello we have Bessie shoes
vessey claims their shoes are 100
waterproof so we can go step into as
many puddles as we want their dimetex
technology keeps their shoes light and
breathable while still being stretchy
and comfortable also all of their
products are vegan and cruelty free
maybe you're planning a trip to get away
from some of this miserable weather
don't forget to pack a pair of essies
their stretchiness means they can easily
pack into your luggage or carry on rain
or shine here or there it's always a
great occasion to wear a pair of vessies
mon frere go to vessi.com Linus Tech
tips and get 15 off your purchase with
code Linus Tech tips
another time Loop successfully closed if
you enjoyed this video you can check out
maybe the coolest implementation of our
dna3 the Rog Ally that thing is sick and
really really efficient